sometimes it's impossible to separate
the company from the founder Mark
Zuckerberg and Facebook Steve Jobs and
Apple yuan mosque and Tesla for better
or worse it's hard to see anyone
thinking about who were without quickly
thinking about you know Travis kalanick
but that's not always a good thing for
the company that's earth Newcomb and
cover number and startups for uber
Callen ik has become a lightning rod of
controversy in the tech industry over
the past three years Seth Meyer said
he's what happens when you react body
pray into the suit until it became
sentient and after a number of damaging
scandals panic resigned as CEO from a 69
billion dollar brainchild this is the
story of Travis kalanick that one of the
most successful and controversial tech
companies in the world
the 1976 in Los Angeles intended UCLA to
study engineering and he also started
his first company an online file
exchange service called scour with some
of his UCLA classmates months before
graduating he dropped out to work on
scour full-time I was back in sort of
the Napster days and it was a sort of a
failed effort Scour ended up getting
sued by every major entertainment label
to the tune of 250 billion dollars and
the company went into chapter 11
undaunted he started another company
called Reds Rouge which was another
peer-to-peer file-sharing service the
company Acme bought it for nineteen
million which was obviously a nice
success for Travis but I think from his
perspective he didn't build the empire
that he'd hoped to flush with cash after
selling read swoosh Kanak was looking to
make his next move the story goes he was
in Paris with his friend Garrett camp
who had founded social sites StumbleUpon
and they started talking about this idea
of calling a car with a push of a button
he started uber originally called uber
cab in 2009 it was first thought of as a
luxury service it was a black car
business in the beginning it wasn't it
sort of peer-to-peer ride-sharing it was
you know nice black cars and this was
meant to get a car whenever they wanted
to get a nice car but when its main
competitor and
the marketplace in 2012 uber had to
pivot once it was obvious that lyft was
going to be successful and be able to do
this peer-to-peer ride-sharing business
he was savvy enough to launch his own
product so Callen ik well known as an
extremely strong salesperson raised a
huge amount of money they raised
hundreds of millions from around from
Google Ventures and key PG and created
uber X which is really the defining
product which lets people sign up with
basically the car they have without
having to have been this legacy black
car worker almost single-handedly
calendar created what we now call the
gig economy paying independent
contractors through an app for a service
whether it's cleaning a home delivering
food or being a chauffeur even though
the company is 12,000 people now you
very much has a reputation for trying to
sort of cut through bureaucracy and keep
it like a startup mechanic has also been
criticized for a number of incidents the
Buber incident comes up sort of so often
in a 2014 GQ profile of Callen ik he
referred to his company as Boober
because of his increased success with
women as the CEO of uber then the PR
missteps kept coming just the first
three months of 2017 alone there were
enough gas leaked videos and negative
headlines that can easily think a
company laying everything out there's
this constant clamor for him to grow up
the company is sort of in the middle of
trying to decide whether he can really
be their identity both publicly and
internally in February of 2017 the board
hired former attorney General Eric
Holder to investigate the company
following a bombshell blog post from a
former uber employee accusing the
company of systemic sexual misconduct
several days after uber released a 13
page report Kanak announced he'd be
taking a leave of absence a week later
he resigned as CEO so while the question
used to be who will Kanak hire SS number
two the question now is how the company
will successfully navigate the post
Callen ik era
you